jung fäch und offen so präsentieren sich
heute viele junge Jäger und Jägerinnen
in den sozialen
Medien ich würde jetzt noch mal eben fix
eine Story
machen selbstbewusst gewähren sie
Einblicke in eine Welt die früher als
geschlossene Gesellschaft älterer
herrenalt bevor ich was mit der Jagd zu
tun hatte dachte ich eich gesagt auch
immer das machen nur alte Leute mit
Dackel und dicken
Bauch
nachhaltiger Fleischkonsum Waldumbau in
Zeiten des Klimawandels und der Wunsch
nach einem intensiven
Naturerlebnis diese Beweggründe geben
viele Jungjäger
an mir ist es sehr sehr wichtig dass
jedem klar wird dass die Jagd viel viel
mehr bedeutet als nur das todschießen
von
Wild befindet sich die Jagd tatsächlich
im Wandel oder geht es um die
Inszenierung auf der Jagd nach Klicks
und
[Musik]
[Applaus]
Likes ein Gutshof in Thüringen für
einige Tage der Hotspot der deutschen
jagdinfluenzerzene hier bringt eine
Agentur influencer jagdausstatter und
professionelle Fotografen zusammen um
die Jagd in Szene zu
setzen schön dass Ihr alle da seid im
herrlichen Thüringen jagen wir jetzt die
nächsten Tage auf rewld Dammwild
Schwarzwild und Rotwild wir werden
morgens und abends rausgehen tagsüber
Content erstellen und ansonsten wünsche
ich Euch und uns erstmal eine tolle
Woche früh morgens geht es los die
influenzer wollen in den umliegenden
Revieren Beute machen mit Büchse und mit
Kamera auch Luna macht sich auf die
Pirsch die 32-Jährige hat ihren
Jagdschein ihr grünes Abitur erst vor
einem Jahr gemacht seitdem lässt sie das
Jagdfieber nicht mehr los wenn dann so
langsam die Sonne aufgeht und über die
Felder und die Wiesen und die Bäume vor
allem jetzt der herbstjahreszeit ist
einfach
wunderschön mit dabei ist Florian er
betreut als Berufsjäger das Revier und
begleitet regelmäßig Jagdgäste wie Luna
ich selber komme nicht aus einer
traditionellen jagdfamilie sondern aus
der Stadt und habe wirklich
dadurch dass ich mit anderen erfahrenen
Jäger rausgegangen bin
wieder einen Bezug zur Natur
gefunden für viele Jungjäger sind solche
geführtenjten in fremdrevieren oft die
einzige Möglichkeit praktische Erfahrung
zu
sammeln Luna möchte einen Hirsch erlegen
der auf dem Abschussplan des
revierinhabers
[Musik]
steht wir warten mal der nur 50
mter natürlich super spannend
man man kann es ja mehr hören als
[Musik]
sehen doch der Hirsch tritt nicht aus
dem Dickicht hervor Luna und Florian
brechen ab ohne Beute und vorerst ohne
[Musik]
Bilder ich mach dann im Nachhinein gerne
auch mal Fotos oder versuch dann noch
mal Moment einzufangen ähm aber wenn ich
wirklich am pürchen bin dann brauche ich
auch die Hände frei muss sehr
konzentriert sein und deswegen geht da
meistens das Foto oder F machen her
[Musik]
unter der Misserfolg bei der Jagd ist
schnell vergessen so bleibt mehr Zeit
die neue Jagdausrüstung zu präsentieren
wie andere influenzerinnen ihre Kleider
Lippenstifte oder yogaposen zur
schaustellen
das schaut gut
aus Posts für die Pflege des Netzwerks
von
[Musik]
Jägern ich fin halt einfach wichtig
gerade wenn man noch am Anfang der Jagd
steht den anderen auch mitzuteilen womit
man zufrieden ist also jeder jagt ja
anders aber mit dem wo ich zufrieden bin
das teile ich gerne mit weil so habe ich
natürlich dann auch meine Produkte
vorher durch andere Jäger gefunden
Community und und Kommerz dieses Rezept
funktioniert für
Luna beim anstehenden Fotoshooting
treffen die influencer so auf
potenzielle Werbepartner okay und los
geht's zwischendurch spontane Lacher
einbauen ein jagdausstatter lässt
frischen Content
produzieren Loden ist eher traditionell
das heißt auch eher bei den älteren
Jägern bekannt oder beliebt und die
Jugend kommt erst drauf und das ist
natürlich
Media influencing das ganze ist gutes
Tool um die Reichweite für die Jugend zu
generieren also der finanzielle Aufwand
im Vergleich zur Reichweite ist
eigentlich sehr
gut das Geschäft boomt über 1,5
Milliarden Euro geben deutsche
Jägerinnen und Jäger pro Jahr für ihre
Leidenschaft aus und immer mehr Anbieter
buen um die
Kundschaft be anschaut das ganz geil
nach dem Fotoshooting begutachten die
jagdinfluencer ihre digitalen Trophäen
der vergangenen
Tage der Veranstalter des Camps ist
selbstpassionierter Jäger und Inhaber
einer
Werbeagentur das Image muss
stimmen uns aber auch den Marken die wir
betreuen ist einfach eine ethisch
korrekte weitgerechte Darstellung der
Jagd in den sozialen Netzwerken extrem
wichtig und fangs haben wir das auch mit
deutschen jachtverband geschult bei den
ersten drei Camps weil natürlich jeder
Post jeder Beitrag jedes Video jede real
hat ist ein Stück weit
Öffentlichkeitsarbeit die Mühe um das
Image scheint sich zu lohnen Jagd liegt
voll im Trend während es 1990 rund 310
000 Jagdscheininhaber in Deutschland gab
sind es heute schon fast
410.000 ein Zuwachs von gut
30% mit weiter steigender Tendenz
einer der die neuen Jäger ausbildet ist
Daniel
Bastian der 41-Jährige ist Berufsjäger
und betreibt eine Jagdschule in der
Eifel seit der Eröffnung vor zwei Jahren
sind die Kurse immer gut
besucht gerade durch Corona waren viele
Dinge gar nicht mehr möglich dann hat im
Prinzip auch der letzte Städter entdeckt
dass die Natur schön ist weil wandern
das ging eigentlich zu jeder Zeit und
man ist rausgegangen und jetzt hat das
doch auch bei dem ein oder anderen das
Interesse geweckt in Kombination mit
nachhaltiger Fleischgewinnung was auch
immer mehr zum Thema wird und so kommt
doch der ein oder andere auch zum
Jagdschein viele Interessierte haben
noch keinerlei Bezug zur Jagd und
stammen aus dem urbanen
Raum die Klientel wird immer
gemischter heutzutage kommt der Jäger
aus jeder Gesellschaftsschicht das heißt
vom Handwerker bis zum Akademiker der
Frauenanteil der steigt vor allen Dingen
auch aktuell im aktuellen Kurs haben wir
eine Frauenquote von
40%. bundesweit traten 2022 rund 24.000
Menschen zum grünen Abitur an davon fast
ein Drittel Frauen das
Durchschnittsalter aller Prüflinge lag
bei 35
Jahren die verpflichtenden
Vorbereitungskurse umfassen rund 100 50
Stunden Theorie und Praxis und Kosten
durchschnittlich 2200 €. im Schnitt
fallen 25% aller Jagdscheinanwärter am
Ende durch die
[Musik]
Prüfung und nicht jeder der besteht ist
hinterher gut genug
ausgebildet zumal es immer mehr Schüler
gibt die ihren Jagdschein in nur zwei
oder drei Wochen per Crashkurs
absolvieren für die stark verkürzte
Ausbildung da ist heutzutage auch
wirklich ein erhöhter Bedarf da immer
mehr Leute den Jagdschein machen aber
leider Gottes immer in kürzerer Zeit und
sich unserer Meinung nach nicht über
eine ausreichend lange Zeit mit dem
Thema beschäftigen und dann gehen viele
Dinge einfach unter in der Kürze der
Ausbildung bei Daniel Bastian dauert die
Ausbildung mindestens ein halbes Jahr er
will seinen Schülern und Schülerinnen
Zeit geben sich mit der Komplex Materie
vertraut zu machen und ihnen ökologische
Zusammenhänge vermitteln die über die
reine Trophäenjagd
hinausgehen die Jagd als
verantwortungsvolle Aufgabe statt als
bloßes Hobby so sieht das auch Lina aus
der Nähe von kuckshafen die 26-Jährige
hat vor 3 Jahren das grüne Abitur
gemacht ja wenn ich mal Mitmenschen
erzähl dass ich Jägerin bin dann sind
die Reaktion meistens dieselben sie sind
meistens sehr verwundert weil ich ja
noch nicht dem klassischen Bild einer
Jägerin entspreche von daher finde ich
das noch umso wichtiger einfach auch zu
zeigen dass vielleicht auch kleine
blonde Mädchen oder auch Frauen das
hinbekommen zu jagen und das auch gut
machen deswegen berichtet Lina
regelmäßig aus dem Revier sie ist eine
der erfolgreichsten deutschen
jagdinfluenzerinnen mit mehr als 30000
follow auf
Instagram fotografier am besten quer
dann krieg du das alles glaube ich am
besten mit drauf Ninas jüngere Schwester
Lara schießt nur mit der Kamera statt
mit der
Büchse ich lieg hier heute zusammen mit
meinem Pächter ein Wildacker an weil wir
hier ringsrum nur Maisflächen haben dass
wir noch eine Ausgleichsfläche haben
damit die Tierwelt ein bisschen
esungsangebot und auch Deckung hat sei
es das Reh oder die Biene die sich hier
ihre Pollen
wegholt Fotos und Kurzvideos der der
Feldarbeit postet Lina später auf ihrem
Instagram
Account wenn meine Schwester Zeit hat
näm ichimmer ganz gerne für Fotos mit
und ansonsten hab ich mein Handy auch
immer selber dabei für Stories dass die
Leute auch einfach sehen wie vielfältig
die Jagd ist und was die Jagd auch alles
umfasst dass es eben nicht nur darum
geht um die Erlegung eines wildes
sondern dass wir auch viel in der Natur
unterwegs sind auch die Hege und Pflege
betreiben ich unterstützt sie da auch
voll bei ich finde das gut was sie macht
auch mit Social Media dass sie in den
anderen Leuten auch ihre Sichtweise zeig
dass sie nicht falsch da drüber
denken Inszenierung der Jagd und
Selbstdarstellung geht es hier aber
vielleicht auch um
Rechtfertigung ich habe ja nicht wegen
der Fotografie die Jagd angefangen
sondern andersrum ich habe mein
Jagdschein gemacht aus dem
Nachhaltigkeitsaspekt weil ich mein
Fleisch selbst erlegen wollte und bin
ich im Supermarkt kaufen wollte und mein
Jagd habe ich jetzt 3 Jahre und mit der
Fotografie mache ich jetzt ungefähr
eineinhalb bis zwe Jahre von daher hat
sich das dann so ein bisschen ergänzt
und auch
entwickelt nach der Fotopirsch ist vor
der Bildbearbeitung Lina verbringt fast
genauso viel Zeit mit der Hege und
Pflege ihres Instagram Accounts wie im
Revier sie kuratiert ihre Bilder sehr
genau will die Jagd bewusst und
ästhetisch in Szene setzen ja das hat
Lara sehr gut gemacht das ist auf jeden
Fall was dabei ich schaue jetzt mal ob
ich noch eine Detailaufnahme
finde Lina passt sehr genau auf wie sie
sich auf Social Media präsentiert sie
will Follower ohne jagdbezug nicht durch
blutige Fotos
abschrecken Fotos auf denen sie sich mit
einem frisch geschossenen Tier in Szene
setzt postet sie selten verklärt sie
damit nicht das Töten eines Tieres es
geht auf meinem nicht darum irgendwas zu
beschönigen die Erlegung eines wildes
gehört dazu das ist ein Prozess bis man
ein Stück erlegt man muss sich viele
Gedanken darüber machen wo steht das
Wild wie ist das Wetter von wo kommt der
Wind das ist ja ein ganz langer Weg bis
man wirklich ein Stück erlegt und ich
finde wenn es dann geklappt hat und man
Tier weitgerecht und ohne
Qualen erlegen konnte dann kann man sich
schon drüber freuen das ist nichts
verwerflich ist meiner Meinung nach
ethisch sauber getötetes wild zur
nachhaltigen Fleischgewinnung darum gehe
es ihr sagt sie ja hier z.B da konnte
ich meinen ersten Bock erlegen in diesem
Revier und ich bin halt bemüht das ganze
Drumrum der Jagd einfach festzuhalten
und im besten Fall auch Leute vor allen
auch Jägerinnen dazu animieren zu können
zu zeigen hey guck mal ich habe auch
vorher jagdlich gar keine Erfahrung
gehabt ich bin die erste in der Familie
die den Jagdschein hat und trotzdem
funktioniert
es aber wandelt sich die Jagd wirklich
oder nur ihr Image durch perfekte
[Musik]
Selbstdarstellung in seinem jagdschul
Revier in der Eifel will Daniel Bastian
jedenfalls ein umfassendes und
zeitgemäßes Naturverständnis
vermitteln heute auf dem Stundenplan das
Zusammenspiel von hege Pflege Jagd und
zukunftsorientiertem Waldumbau in Zeiten
des
Klimawandels zum Thema Waldumbau welches
Ziel hat man denn heute in der
Forstwirtschaft oder zu welchem Waldtyp
wollen wir denn hin zu einem Mischwald
bzw naturn genau richtig wir können uns
das jetzt aber gerne im Wald mal
[Musik]
angucken die Jagd als spannende
Spurensuche im tatortwald Voraussetzung
für die Abschussplanung und das
wildmanagement im
Revier das ist
ganz was haben wir hier denn jetzt
rotwildlosung ne drehbildlosung würde
ähnlich aussehen aber viel kleiner ganz
genau durch die Jagdschule ist es so
dass man die Umwelt komplett anders
wahrnimmt also durch so ein Jagdschein
wird das einem halt selber auch viel
mehr klar dass es noch viel mehr ist als
nur dieses erlegen vom
Wild laut Umfrage des Deutschen
Jagdverbandes Schein neben nachhaltiger
Fleischgewinnung auch ein intensives
Naturerlebnis und der Umweltschutz für
viele Jungjäger die wichtigste
Motivation wie können wir denn
überprüfen jagen wir zu wenig jagen wir
zu viel ja auf jeden Fall an Schäl oder
Verbissschäden die halt vermehrt
auftreten und das liegt an euch das zu
erkennen und als Fachmann richtig zu
beurteilen in den allerseltensten Fällen
wird sinnhaft hinterfragt wird denn hier
wie wird hier überhaupt
gejagt eine Frage die angesichts von
Klimawandel und zunehmender
Freizeitnutzung der Natur in der
Jagdausbildung neues Gewicht bekommt
immer öfter gehe es um Pflanzenschutz
statt
trophäenammeln in Zeiten des waldumbaus
ist es natürlich wichtig dass wir das
Wild nicht anfangen wie ein Schädling zu
behandeln weder der totalabschuss noch
völlig überhöhte Wildbestände können das
Ziel sein wir möchten unseren angehenen
Jägern das notwendige Fachwissen mit auf
den Weg geben dass sie immer Wald mit
einem angepassten Wildbestand als
oberstes Ziel
haben den Wildbestand anpassen dazu
braucht der Jäger immer noch sein
wichtigstes Werkzeug das Gewehr
[Musik]
die angehenden Prüflinge nehmen in der
Jagdschule meist zum ersten Mal in ihrem
Leben eine echte Waffe in die
Hand heute spielen sie mit Daniel
Bastian den Ablauf jagdlicher
Situationen
durch jetzt kommt ein Reburg was machst
du das den reborg Versuchen richtig
anzusprechen mit fnglas ganz genau jetzt
möchtest du den erlegen wie gehst du
weiter vor äh dann würde ich die Waffe
aufnehmen mhm bitte mach
das
so so und dann unmittelbar erst vor dem
Schuss die waffean mach das mal Anschlag
so auf dem Stück spannen wir erst die
Waffe ne das heißt wir gehen den
Anschlag und spannen dann die Waffe gut
dann passt soweit alles du entscheidest
dich zum Schuss da müsstest mal ein
Schuss
abgeben sehr gut
ich bin halt schon aufgeregt dabei weil
es ja schon eine Schusswaffe die man da
ein an hat in der Hand hat
aber ich bin mir halt schon meiner
Aufgabe und auch meiner Verantwortung
bewusst wir wollen keine Schießer
ausbilden oder irgendwelche Cowboys
sollen wir der Überzeugung sein dass
derjenige der sich hier angemeldet hat
nicht geeignet ist um mit einer
Schusswaffe zu hantieren würden wir das
auch jederzeit deutlich kommunizieren
und die Ausbildung dann auch abbrechen
außerdem unterziehen die Behörden jeden
Jagdscheininhaber einem backgroundcheck
bevor er eine eigene Waffe kaufen
darf jagdinfluenzerin Dina aus der Nähe
von kuckshafen hat seit ihrer
Jagdprüfung schon mehrere Tiere
geschossen heute will sie versuchen ein
Reh zu erlegen das Gewehr ist für sie
dabei nur ein
Werkzeug trotzdem das bewusste Töten
eines Tieres bleibt für sie ein
besonderer
Moment ja vor dem Schuss habe ich
ehrlich gesagt gar nicht so viele
Gefühle in mir sondern bin total
fokussiert und konzentriert da bleibt
kein Platz für ängstliche Gedanken oder
was wäre
wenn wenn sich der Schuss dann gelöst
hat und man auf hierier beschossen hat
dann ja wie soll ich das Gefühl
beschreiben gemischte Gefühle man
zweifelt vielleicht ein bisschen oder
hinterfagt sich ob das jetzt richtig war
hat das alles gepasst hat das Tier
wirklich kein Leid erlebt wenn es
natürlich im Knall lag also sofort zu
Boden gegangen ist
dann kommt natürlich die Freude
hinterher aber heute kommen die Rehe
nicht aus der Deckung nur ein Hase wagt
sich auf die Wiese direkt vor
ihr Hasen schieß ich natürlich nicht mit
der Kugel aber mit der Kamera gerne
könnte das den ganzen Tag glaube ich tun
hier sitzen und einfach Tiere beobachten
ich finde das so faszinierend wie sie
sich verhalten in ihrem natürlichen
Umfeld natürlich kann man sich denn
jetzt fragen warum schauen sie mir nicht
nur an sondern schieße sie auch ich
schieße ja nicht das Tier weil ich
Freude dran habe sondern weil ich ein
Lebensmittel erhalten
[Musik]
möchte lina ist auf einem kleinen
Bauernhof nahe der Nordseeküste groß
geworden
er noch heute kümmert sie sich
regelmäßig um die
Tiere ich w mich auf jeden Fall schon
als zeben Menschen bezeichnen ich bin
auf dem Bauernhof groß geworden von
daher K ich das den Umgang mit den
Tieren und das eine schießt das andere
nicht aus nur weil ich jagen heißt es
nicht dass ich kein Tier lieber Mensch
bin also er im Gegenteil das woh der
Tiere ist mir
wichtig l entdeckte die Jagd erst vor d
Jahren durch ihren damaligen Freund für
sich inzwischen ist ne Leidenschaft oft
Thema am
Esstisch wir waren völlig überrascht wie
Lina damit ankam
weil sie da vorher überhaupt kein
Interesse da gezeigt hat und weil wir in
der Familie auch irgendwie nichts mit
Jacht zu tun haben aber die hatte vorher
gar keine Ahnung von irgendwelche
Baumsorten oder Tiere im Wald kannte sie
auch nicht je jedes Tier und heute weiß
ich sehr viel
über und Lina bereichert neben ihrem
Instagram Account auch den heimischen
Speiseplan ja heute gibt bei uns R
bonaes von einem Stück re was ich
erlegen konnte hier ein Ortschaft weiter
sehr lecker mit Bohnensalat hat Mutti
gemacht ja sehr lecker freuen wir uns
wenn Lina was
erlegt jagen um den eigenen
Fleischkonsum zu rechtfertigen diese
Motivation hörtorsten Wagner oft
der6jähge ist von ber licher Jäger er
veranstaltet sogenannte zerwirkseminare
in der Nähe von München um
Interessierten die bestmögliche
fleischverwertung beizubringen wenn man
sich das Gelenk als Ganzes anschaut dann
geht man in die Hälfte und im unteren
Drittel schneidet
man und knickt um und so ist es bei
allen Wildarten wo wir haben bei
uns der Andrang auf die Seminare ist
groß neben Jägern kommen auch Köche
Hobbyköche und selbstversorg
es ist ein ein Lebewesen das sollte man
immer vor Augen haben was man da erlegt
und wir sollten uns es einfach bewahren
mit dem Wild auch sorgsam umgehen vor
und nach dem
Schuss auch Martin hat gerade erst den
Jagdschein gemacht und noch Übungsbedarf
eine reguläre metzg Ausbildung dauert
immerhin ganze 3 Jahre weit aus n
wenn man das sonst nie macht das ist
schon ganz ganz besonderes Gefühl wenn
man quasi so ein Rücken in der Hand hat
mit Knochen das Fleisch noch da dran man
braucht auch Kraft und die richtige
Technik um vielleicht die Rippen zu
durch trennen um das Fleisch rauszulösen
das ist echtes Handwerk ja und wenn man
sonst den ganzen Tag nur im Büro sitzt
ist es echt andere Tätigkeit und ich
glaub dann hat man auch die richtige
Wertschätzung das neue Bewusstsein für
nachhaltige Ernährung wirkt sich
deutlich auf die aus ja es ist ein neuer
Trend zu spüren viele neue Jäger und
nutz natürlich auch die sozialen Medien
wo sie irgendwelche Rezepte kochen und
machen das natürlich dann auch
schmackhaft finde ich gut weil das Wild
ist einfach unschlagbar vom Geschmack
und mehr Bio geht halt nicht ja
grundsätzlich kann man fast alles
verwerten und so werden offensichtlich
für viele junge Jäger Wurst Filet und
Keule zu den Waren Trophäen nachhaltiger
Jagd insgesamt 29 Tonn Wildfleisch
wurden in Deutschland 2021 verzehrt und
der Appetit auf Hirsch Reh und
Wildschwein wächst
weiter wenn ich Freunde treffe zum zum
Grillen und selbstgemachte Würstchen
mitbringe da ist das Erstaunen doch
schon immer ziemlich groß die sind
selber gemacht vielleicht sogar selber
geschossen das Tier aber das haben
Generationen vor uns gemacht Essen sich
zu organisieren und eigentlich sollte es
überhaupt nicht besonderes
sein
nach gut 3 Stunden metzgarbeit folgt die
[Musik]
Fleischveredelung das ist halt einfach
die Vollendung von dem ganzen Prozess
wenn man jetzt noch das eigene wild was
man erlegt hat selber grillen kann man
weiß wo es herkommt es schmeckt einfach
anders wie irgendwo aus dem Supermarkt
die Teilnehmer sind alle schon kräftig
am
Schmatzen
wildfleisch ist reich an Vitaminen und
Mineralstoffen außerdem besonders
mager also schmeckt wirklich sehr sehr
gut von der Konsistenz her super da
läuft kein Fett raus da läuft kein
Wasser raus da merkt man einfach die
Qualität kein Stress auf dem Weg zum
Schlachthof super
lecker beim jagdinfluenzer Camp in
Thüringen steht nun der letzte Ansitz
bevor
maxi hat sich auf die jagdfilmerei
spezialisiert und finanziert damit sein
Studium heute begleitet er Sandra eine
erfahrene Jägerin mit großer Reichweite
bei
[Musik]
Instagram wichtige sch bei der
jagdfilmereihe eigentlich dass man eben
auf den Jäger eingeht und halt auch dem
Hintergrund keine Fehler macht weil
jeder Fehler eigentlich dort kann
natürlich dazu führen dass es wild dann
dem chend
abspringt Maxi produziert Videos für die
deutsche Online Plattform hand on Demand
dort gibt es im Abomodell immer frische
jagdfilme ich bin mal gespannt was mich
erwartet ob wir z Schuss kommen oder
nicht das wird sich zeigen es bleibt auf
jeden Fall
spannend auch das Abenteuer macht die
Jagd so attraktiv ztausende Jäger Teilen
heute ihre Erlebnisse bis hin zum
tödlichen Schuss ganz selbstverständlich
in den sozialen Medien immerhin für
Jägerinnen wie Sandra hat sich dadurch
einiges zum Positiven
geändert als ich den Jagdschein gemacht
habe da war ich wirklich so ein völliges
ausnahmeewewesen wurde da von allen
Seiten angeguckt das ist mittlerweile
auch 12 Jahre her und hab das richtig
die Entwicklung mitbekommen mittlerweile
ist eine Frau auf einer Jagd was völlig
normales und das ist natürlich was super
tolles das haben wir uns ein bisschen
erkämpft jeder kann sich wahrscheinlich
vorstellen das auch auf der Jagd
extrematriarchalstruktur und ja jetzt
gibt's jede Menge Frauen die da ihre
Frau stehen und eben zeigen dass Jagd
keine reine Männerdomäne
ist trotz des Wandels und der neuen
Offenheit den alten Traditionen bleibt
man doch ganz gerne
[Musik]
treu
das ist Tradition und das ist Ehre und
wir müssen das machen und wenn dann der
eine Ton oder der andere nicht passt und
die anderen amüsieren sich vielleicht
ist mir egal weil wir brauchen die
Tradition aber wir brauchen eben auch
die moderne dreifach
kräftiges die influencer legen ihre
sogenannte Jagdstrecke der letzten
Tage sie den toten Tieren die letzte
Ehre erweisen bevor die Beute
schließlich in der Küche landet und in
den sozialen
[Musik]
Medien das ist natürlich auch ein Thema
was für die breite Öffentlichkeit
eventuell schwierig ist ne da liegen
tote Tiere da stehen Menschen die lachen
die freuen sich die haben Spaß ne wo ist
da die Verbindung und da ist es eben
halt auch wieder unsere Aufgabe so ein
bisschen zu transportieren das ist keine
Trauergeschichte wir freuen uns wir
freuen über Erlebnisse wir freuen uns
über tolle gemeinsame Zeit die Natur
erlebt zu haben wir freuen uns natürlich
auch über gewonnenes Wildfleisch und
nichtsdestotrotz heißt das nicht dass
hier keiner das Wild ert dass hier
keiner irgendwie nicht Respekt vor der
Kreatur hat das haben wir alle und das
ist eben auch ganz ganz
wichtig die Jagd sie wird trotz neuer
Offenheit und Ansätze wohl ein
kontroverses Thema
[Musik]
bleiben